I think that the people who have been
doing political satire or the people
i've talked to have really felt like it
used to be them again the media was the
watchdog for those you know the
government and corporate america and
when the media sort of felt like it was
in bed and they were lazy or in bed with
with their you know advertisers I think
comics naturally started filling the
role of sort of being the watchdog of
the watchdog you know political satire
in comedy we just started asking the
questions that journalists weren't
asking anymore through humor through
sort of hopefully funny righteous anger
but also just asking questions that our
audience wanted to hear and so we were
doing basically a service we just kept
doing we were doing but then it just
transitioned into like find out what's
going on or if we're just going to be
lied to from right left and center to
provide a haven where at least people
can come together and not feel crazy
feel like hey I'm in a group of people
who have understand that everybody
spinning us and somebody's onstage
pointing that out through humor at least
I can breathe a sigh that i'm not insane
when I hear the cacophony of lies
I think comedy can be a tool for social
activism I think that when you point out
hypocrisy again because the media often
doesn't you know the follow-up question
should just be put in the Smithsonian as
a relic of media because there are no
follow-ups anymore people don't have
enough historical knowledge to say wait
you're lying if you don't have enough
you know knowledge on the environment to
say wait scientists say there's global
warming it's real so a lot of
information just sort of floats out
there like like a thick muggy day and
nobody weeds through it and cuts through
the muck and says here's the truth and I
think that pointing that out through
humor can be a tool to have people say
wow I should be asking questions and I'm
laughing and I think that's what's fun
is that you can ask questions yourself
on stage through humor and then that
means the audience kind of scratches its
head and says you're right and as you
watch videos on the web and the daily
show and colbert bill maher you will see
them lay out a case and make it funny
through video through things that are
out there somebody says one thing one
day and something else the next day and
you know we have this amazing medium
with which we can put it out there
you